CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Hello, everyone.
Sorry for the delay.
We've had just some technical
issues, but we finally managed
to get it running.
Welcome back to Google
Developers Live.
My name is Claudio, and I'm one
of the engineers in the
Google Drive Developer
Relations Team.
Today, I want to show you an
Android app that's pretty
popular right now.
It's called Atooma, and it was
built by an Italian team, and
I'm so proud because I'm Italian
myself, so I'm very
happy for them.
And they participated in the
TechCrunch Italy event, and
they won it as the
best product.
So I want to show you what this
app can do and how this
app integrates with Drive.
And I understand the app is
still in beta, so there's some
rough edges here and there,
and I have some
recommendations for the app
to be slightly better.
The app works perfectly.
What I will suggest is just some
small things on the user
experience.
But let me show you the app
first, and then we'll see what
we can do to make it better
and how cool this app is.
So let's move to the tablet.
The app, as I said,
is called Atooma.
What the app does-- sorry, I
didn't even mention that-- but
what the app does is it lets
you automate tasks.
So you can say things like, if
it's late at night, turn the
volume down, things like that.
Or if I'm driving fast, don't
let the phone ring.
Or what I'm going to show you is
if I take a new photo with
my camera, anytime I take a
photo with a camera, upload it
to Drive directly.
So all this kind of automation
can be done with Atooma, and
it's very, very easy to
set up these tasks.
It doesn't require a programmer
or a very technical
person to do it.
I'm going to show you.
So let me start Atooma.
So I click on it.
First thing, this is
kind of weird.
The app always starts
in landscape mode,
even if I'm in Portrait.
So this is one of those small
things that I would like the
team to fix.
You know that I'm in Portrait
Mode, so you shouldn't show
the app rotate the screen.
But still, as soon as you start
the app for the first
time, you get a tutorial,
which is very good.
It explains to you how
to use the app.
So you start with swiping
first page, and once you
swipe, you get a step-by-step
guide.
Sorry, it's still in Landscape,
but I will go very
quickly through this.
And another small usability
thing here.
I swiped to get here, and I
got a new page, so I would
expect here to use swipe
to go to the next page.
But it doesn't actually swipe.
So you have Next buttons here.
So you should be consistent
with the user experience.
If you swipe the first
page, you should
swipe all other pages.
But still, no big deal.
This tutorial will explain
how to use Atooma.
I will do that for you, so
no need to go through it.
So we can skip it from here.
And if you skip it from there,
you will still get it the next
time you run the app.
If you don't want the tutorial
to show up the following time,
you have to go through all the
pages, and at the end, you
have a flag that says don't
run this thing anymore.
So now that the application is
running, you can create your
tasks, your things to
do with Atooma, and
they're called Atooma.
So it's very easy.
You click on New Atooma, and
it's basically two steps.
You have to define what the
condition is, so when to do
something, and then
what to do.
The first part is called
If, and the second
part is called Do.
So you have different categories
here to be used.
So you have from data, from
mobile, from apps.
And let's say what I want to
build is this Atooma that
says, every time I take a new
photo with my camera, upload
it to Drive.
So I'm going to click on Mobile,
and you have this nice
wheel with all the options,
all the categories,
subcategories.
What I want here
is the camera.
So I click on Camera.
And then I have two options,
New Photo or New Video.
So you can have an Atooma that
starts whenever you take a new
photo or a new video.
And I'm going to
use New Photo.
And that's basically it.
If you want, you can add
multiple conditions.
So whenever I take a photo and
it's late at night, or
whenever I take a photo
and my battery is not
low, things like that.
But for us, this is
going to be just
whenever I take a photo.
So I don't need to specify
any other details, so
I can move to Do.
What I want to do now is saving
the file to Drive.
So I will go to Apps.
I have multiple options here.
It's nice Atooma that integrates
with different
properties, not just
Google ones.
So you can have Gmail actions,
you can have Google Drive
actions, but you can also have
others like Facebook, or
Dropbox, or many others.
What I want to show you
here is Google Drive.
So I click on Google Drive, and
you have multiple actions
which you can select here.
And what I want to do is add
the file to Drive, so I'll
click on Add File.
Now I have to specify some
details about the actions I
want to perform.
So I can select to add this file
to a specific folder in
my Drive, and if I do, Atooma
lists the folders I have in my
Drive account.
And this UI was built by Atooma,
and this is built by
using the Drive API.
So they list the folders, and
if you click on one, it goes
inside the folder and gives you
the sub-folders and so on.
But let's say this is OK.
Any folder, I don't
really care.
I selected the root.
You can select a sub-folder if
you want to categorize your
photos somewhere.
And that's a first step, and
then you have to select which
file you want to
save to Drive.
It can be any file, or it can
be the one we just took from
the camera.
So this links the action
with the previous step.
So I select the camera and the
new photo I just took.
Say OK, and that's
basically it.
I said if I take a photo, do
save the photo to Drive, and
then this equals a new Atooma.
And you have to name.
I can name it Drive Upload.
And on the top here, you see the
summary with nice icons, a
summary of the rule
you created.
And then you have to
tag your Atooma.
So all Atoomas are tagged, and
so you have to select as many
tags as you want for
categorization.
I was kind of surprised here,
because I read one of the
categories as [? one of the ?]
tags is called Drive and I
thought that was Google Drive,
and it's actually not.
It's when you're driving.
So I wish we had these clear.
But let's say this can be
Photo Sharing, and maybe
others, and Storage,
maybe, and Apply.
And then I can save
the Atooma.
Another small optimization I
would recommend here is to
automatically select the tags
or suggest some tags.
So whenever I created the
Atooma, you know I'm going to
use the camera, you know I'm
going to use storage.
So maybe you can preselect
Camera and Storage and suggest
them so that the user
doesn't have to.
But of course, if I want
to change them, I can.
Just small optimization, so
another step that you take out
from the user.
And then I can save.
The Atooma has been saved.
It's not active yet.
Maybe here, the app should ask
you whether you want to enable
it right now, because right
now it's not enabled.
Oh, I just noticed the typo in
"Upload." Anyway, so if you
want to enable it, you can long
click on the Atooma here,
or you can just click on it--
and maybe I'll edit
the typo, sorry.
I don't want people to know
that I can't spell.
I swear I can spell.
Upload, yay.
Save.
So I was saying, if you want
to enable it, you can long
press there or you can enter the
details and then click on
this check box, and
now it's enabled.
Now Atooma is running and this
is enabled, so let's try it.
I'll leave it running there.
You can configure the app to be
running anytime your phone
is running.
And then I can take
a photo here.
Let's say my camera, my hand.
So let's take a photo
of my hand.
Photo has been saved.
What Atooma will do right now is
checking that a new photo's
been uploaded, been saved
to the local device, and
automatically upload to my
Google Drive account.
If everything worked, I can open
my Drive account here,
and wait for it to refresh,
and check if
there are new items.
And I see a new file here that
was just created, and I open
it to Gallery, and
this is my hand.
This is magic.
As the Atooma team says, this
is some kind of magic.
You have very easy things
that you can configure,
and they just work.
So you can build this app
yourself if you want.
We have a Quick Start that
explains how to build an app
that takes a photo
and automatically
syncs them to Drive.
But this, of course, is much,
much easier than writing an
Android app yourself.
And of course, you have multiple
options and multiple
things you can do with Atooma.
Let me go back to the app.
So now that I have this Atooma,
of course, I can
create more.
Now, one thing that I can do is
I can share my Atooma with
other users.
And of course, I can check
their Atoomas.
So maybe you created one very
important rule or very useful
rule and you want others to use
it, so you can share it to
what is called the Wall.
So if I click on My Atooma, the
bottom left corner, I see
an icon that says
Post on Wall.
If I click on this, it
will automatically be
added to the Wall.
What I was expecting here was
actually a confirmation
dialog, maybe for me to check
the name, like if I
had a typo as before.
But still, this is already
on the Wall.
I can go back, and I
can see the Wall.
And you can see there is a lot
of rules here that other
people have created.
You can filter by category,
so that's where
the tags become useful.
So I can filter by them.
Or you can see the
latest ones, and
mine is probably there.
There it is, and it says
that I have it
installed and I got it.
One thing that I couldn't find
is how to delete an Atooma
from the Wall.
So I can delete my Atooma from
my local device, but I cannot
remove it from the Wall.
And I'm not sure if that is by
design, but what if I created
a bad one and I want
to remove it?
It's probably a good idea
for owners to be
able to remove them.
And it might be interesting to
have some kind of curation to
the content here.
Because some Atooma names are
not very useful, and some
Atoomas are not that useful, and
some duplicates in there.
So maybe it can be useful for
users to have some curation
here from some managers.
If I go inside My Atooma, I also
found a small bug here,
and this is for the
Atooma team.
So I'm in Pacific Time, and the
Atooma team is in Italy,
and they probably had noticed
that I have a
different time zone here.
So my Atooma here shows as
created seven hours in the
past, and this is obviously
not true.
So small things.
Of course, this is a beta.
It works perfectly, but some
things can be just better.
Well, we can create another
Atooma, just
another one is very nice.
I created it, it was fun.
Let's go to Apps and say
every time a Google
Drive file is added--
and you might want to restrict
this to some specific file
name-- but I say, every time a
file is added to Google Drive,
you can do crazy things
like text to
speech and speak something.
So you can use this as a
notifier that tells you when
the new file is added.
So you can speak something,
and it will just read
the text for you.
So I don't know, "file added,"
and you will know.
It's very loud, actually.
So I tried it.
Well, I'm not setting
it right now.
And just another thing.
Let me go back.
Yeah, I don't want
to save this.
And there is another tab here.
It's called Me.
And this is very nice because
it shows you who I am.
So I logged in with my account,
my test account.
It shows how many Atoomas I
have, how many I downloaded,
how many I published.
And you can select some settings
here, so whether to
show the notification icon,
and there are some other
settings here.
You can get in touch
with the Support.
And the best part here
is Connections.
So in Connections, it shows
here what services you're
already connected to.
So my Google Drive account is
on, so I already signed in and
went through the authorization
process, so I can use the
Drive account anytime I want.
But I can also add Dropbox
accounts here, or Twitter,
Facebook, Gmail, or Instagram.
And the first time you enable
them, you will have to go
through whatever the
authorization
process is for that tool.
And I found another thing that I
would like to be fixed here.
So let's say I go to
Instagram and I
want to enable Instagram.
What happens is that
I am brought to the
Authorization page.
Perfect.
So I have to grant access to
Instagram so that I can get
resources from my Instagram
account.
But what if I change my mind,
I get to this page and I
decide not to authorize
the app for Instagram?
A user will just go back.
If you go back to Atooma, Atooma
will not properly react
to that, and it will just stay
there for a while and then
eventually try to have
you log again to
Instagram or get stuck.
So it's thinking about it.
Now it worked, so I'm
probably wrong.
And I tried again, I just
clicked there, closed it.
So I just get there, this black
page should go directly
to the previous page.
So small things, but it would
be better to fix them before
the general availability
release, so the final release.
Anyway, that's basically
it for Atooma.
It's very useful.
I would totally recommend
you to try it.
And their integration with
Drive is very smooth.
You have multiple things
you can do with Drive.
You can add file, delete file,
check for storage space.
Or, for instance, you can say
whenever the storage space is
very low, send me a message,
things like that.
It can automate your
daily activity.
And I also spoke to the Atooma
team yesterday, and I asked
about new features from
Drive at least.
And they mentioned the option
to save Gmail attachments
directly from there, so directly
from Gmail to Drive,
things like that, or to get a
notification when someone
edits a collaborative Google
Docs or Spreadsheet.
So that's another event you can
use to trigger something.
And that's very useful, because
you have a Google
Document, and you don't know
if someone is checking it,
editing it, changing something,
and you can use
Atooma as a way to be notified
of any changes.
For what concerns the technology
they're using,
obviously, they're using
the Drive API.
I didn't ask, but I'm pretty
sure they're checking the
Changes feed.
So by checking their feed, you
will know if someone changes
something in your Docs.
And they're not using it yet,
but we recently announced an
early access program for Push
notification for Drive.
So if you're interested in
this, you can go to our
website, developers.googl
e.com/drive/eap,
Early Access Program.
And from there, you can ask to
be added to this early access
program, which gives you access
to push notification,
and real-time collaboration,
and other features that we
cannot really talk about here.
So I'm very sure Atooma will be
interested in that, and I
will invite them to
check this out.
Because right now, they
have to pull changes.
With that, they will get some
real-time push notifications
so that they can notify users in
real time, and that's even
better than pulling.
And with that, that's
basically it.
You'll find Atooma on the Play
Store, so just go to
play.google.com and search
for Atooma, or go to
www.atooma.com, and you
will find a lot of
information about it.
If you have feedback about this,
please reach out to us,
but also, of course, reach out
to the Atooma team, and I'm
pretty sure we will both be
happy to get your feedback.
Thank you very much, and see
you next time on Google
Developers Live.
Bye.